my name is Laur Deo and I work at the
United States Geological Survey today
I'll be talking about a package I
developed and maintained for the USGS
called Data
retrieval what is USGS it's a United
States federal government agency its
mission is to monitor analyze and
predict current and evolving Earth
system interactions and deliver
actionable information to decision
makers the USGS has scientists that
studied
volcanoes earthquakes ecosystems and has
a long history of making cool maps but
what I'm here to tell about today is the
story of USGS water data and how you can
get that into
R there's a huge variety of data that
the USGS collects concerning water
surface water data includes things like
gauge height and discharge scientists
use this data to study how water levels
are changing over time monitor Current
River conditions and predict flooding
the USGS also studies ground water data
this includes information about Springs
and Wells that indicate aquifer
conditions we can use this data to
understand how human activities and
climate change affects uh the supply of
groundwater there are estimates for how
much water is used in the United States
and generally what that water is used
for water use data might include things
like the volume of water used for
irrigation or the amount of water in a
public water supply
system water quality data includes
physical data like temperature chemical
data and biolog iCal data uh for example
with water quality data we can study the
effects of road salt on streams or lakes
or maybe we're looking at chemicals of
emerging concern such as pesticides
microplastics or
posos I started at the USGS about 13
years ago and not too long after that I
was asked to learn R it was around then
that the USGS was deciding to to move
our support officially from SAS to R
there were some scientists already using
R but it wasn't very widespread for the
most part part Excel was King keep in
mind our studio at that time hadn't been
around much and alternative idees were
not very user friendly one thing that
became obvious right away that it was
very difficult to get our USGS water
data into R this data bottleneck seemed
like the first big hurdle that would
need to be overcome to convince people
to invest in the time to learn
R I'd been hired into a smaller group
within the USGS that had a great mix of
scientists and software developers this
meant that from the very beginning of my
art development I was being taught about
version control unit testing project
management and other software management
uh development best practices and so on
one fateful day in November 2012 I
pushed up a set of code to GitHub there
were some hurdles we had to jump through
to work in the open but I've been lucky
to have had extremely supportive
supervisors who advocate for open source
development it did not take long to
start seeing some immediate benefits of
creating a package to help users get
their data standardizing the data
retrieval phase of code made
collaborating EAS easier and jumping
into analyzing the data quicker more
emphasis was being placed on
reproducible science and data retrieval
made that a little easier Community
engagement flourished we introduced uh
still active GitHub and gitlab
organizations social media blogging and
various training
sessions data retrieval has been
downloaded over 186,000 times for a
pretty Niche package that's good data
retrieval users are fantastic at finding
problems with our data and services and
honestly that's really they're also
really great at helping fix those
problems there have been many US GSR
packages developed over the years uh we
recently got a posit connect license and
it's been a joy to watch it flourish
with shiny apps quto reports and plumber
apis as the main point of contact for
data retrieval I've been contacted by
users in many different fields and it's
a real highlight of my career I wanted
to share some examples of all the cool
projects that use data retrieval but
this talks way too short and there are
way too many to pick from here's a small
list of examples of topics that I've
known that use data retrieval
extensively there's also been many cool
uh data Vis visualizations that use data
retrieval in their creation process one
recently came out from the New York
Times about groundwater within the USGS
we have a group that creates stunning
water related visualizations and
encourage you all to check out the USGS
vizlab
group as our studio pivoted to posit to
connect with more diverse users so did
the USGS realize we really needed a
similar project product for python so
this last year we officially added
support for both a python and Julia data
retrieval
package I hope what you got from this
talk was that making a relatively small
investment in an r package is a great
way to foster a thriving R Community for
the USGS that's meant people have been
able to get their data analysis faster
with reproducible transparent data
pipelines in our current ERA of Rapid
hydrologic change this is critical for
our USGS Mission if you're interested in
checking out the data retrieval package
here's some links that should help you
get started started thank
you